you spoke in the beginning about the
rapid change in the industry causing
problems I wanted to know if you think
that students should try to keep
up-to-date on things that they've
previously learned if by the time they
graduate it'll already be kind of
evolved 100% everything changes so fast
that now it's incumbent upon all
creators not just students but but
professionals especially professionals
that have been in the industry a while
you know the tip of the typical you know
30-year screenwriter that's you know
seeing it done at all they they find it
difficult to really want to stay on top
of things I think students naturally
just because the generation
they've got they've grown up
multi-platform and they naturally
learned all the new platforms and learn
all the new stuff but I think now we
live in such an oversaturated crazy
technologically advanced time that
really if if you want to stay relevant
you need to figure out how to utilize
and maximize and leverage the new
platforms and the new the new touch
points of the methodology that audiences
are using every single day and it's not
necessarily because the theater is going
away or Netflix is is ensuring that
everything streams it's not necessarily
that I always put it in in reference to
the audience and if you understand your
audience and you can design to the
audience then you're gonna you're gonna
you're gonna be a better creator and if
you start to see audiences operating on
multi platforms as you start to see
audiences really gravitating today into
podcasts podcasts are very big they're
very popular today whereas two three
years ago not as much and but if you you
see a big push into podcast then all of
a sudden that should clue you in to not
just there's an opportunity in the
platform but to the mindset of the
audience and once you start to
understand the audience you will be able
to to take that psychology
lace it through how you're going to
create your IP I think a lot of the new
platforms with with mobile with with
with podcast with you know like like
Alexa
you know Alexa Google home you know all
that stuff I think understanding how
that is starting to shift culture why
are people using voice and why is voice
coming back it's almost like we're
coming back to like a 1930s radio area
era again I think instead of being
instead of being threatened by that that
creators screenwriters directors authors
they they should recognize that and use
that as an asset and a tool to be able
to leverage their IP into those things
what I typically get is well I don't
know how to make a podcast I don't know
how to make an Alexa skill I don't know
how to do any of that stuff and you know
it's like you can't teach old dogs new
tricks and I just don't believe that
there's you know I tell a lot of people
there's this there's this amazing
website that you can go to that teaches
you how to do anything in the world it's
goog le com you go there type in how do
I make a podcast how do I create an
Alexa skill how do I do something on IG
TV and you can spend seven or nine or
three or 48 hours reading and learning
how to do all this stuff and all of a
sudden now you have a you have an extra
tool on your Batman belt as a
screenwriter as a producer as a director
not necessarily to replace your movie or
your television show but to be able to
augment it in a way that is is flowing
in line with culture and that I think is
empowering rather than threatening so
I'm a big advocate of never stop
learning especially as a creator because
if you never stop learning you're always
going to be in line with your audience
excellent anything else how do we differ
the how do we differentiate between
transmedia as like a marketing strategy
compared to like a storytelling
strategies should I be using transmedia
in my storytelling part of it or is it
just a marketing ploy
so I've historically bad trends media
has been I think rooted in marketing and
what what happened nothing against
marketing marketing people great you
need good marketing marketing is not a
bad term it's not a pejorative term at
all but where where trends media breaks
down is when creators push the trends
media off to the marketing people that
really don't understand the story or
really they don't have the right to
extend the story and so so a lot of
times you will see marketing marketing
heavy trends media pushes that are light
on story and it's more about you know
just trying to exploit a medium create
an entry point for an audience and there
isn't a valuable extension of the story
so so for me the best trends media comes
from flows through the Creator into all
these touch points to where now the
mobile game and the comic book and the
Facebook live and the IG TV series
whatever it is the podcast they're not
just marketing tools they're
storytelling tools and the big
difference is how much story are you
getting or is it is a story first or is
it just promotional first the more
promotional it is the less valuable it
is to the audience I always like it it
to to you know i me my wife have two
dogs we we love our dogs we're like
weird dog people that like love our dogs
too much and so I oh excuse me I always
use the analogy that you need to feed
your audience and feed your fans like
you feed your dogs and that that if
that's the first lesson you learn as a
kid if when you get a dog is that you
need to feed your dog every day it's
your responsibility that's what my dad
told me he said if we're getting a dog
you're gonna take care of it it's your
responsibility to feed it every single
day and and creators need to have that
same attitude when it comes to their to
their fans it's their responsibility to
continue to feed the fans
it's don't don't Slough it off into a
marketing person or to a publicist or to
other people to pas and interns you need
to now understand this as a creator how
do I feed the audience which then begs
the question what's the best food to
feed the audience the best food to feed
the audience is story it's it's it's as
a Game of Thrones fan the best thing you
can you can feed me is Game of Thrones
story right not necessarily gaming from
its commercial or trailer I get excited
about those things but those are like
sugar rushes right so if you eat if you
eat a bunch of sugar if you feed your
dog just sort of junk that made you know
if you feed it a treat it may get
excited but that's not going to nourish
them over the long term and so so the
thing that nourishes the audience the
most is just honest-to-god good story
and so if you if if you tell me as a
Game of Thrones fan that there is great
story
delivered on Instagram I don't care that
it's Instagram I go there for the story
and I consume that story and now there's
a brand equity that that continues to
strengthen to me for the the game of
thrones brand in general because they
fed me and the more you feed your
audience the more loyal they are right
because I mean if you don't feed your
dog what happens they they either die
they go somewhere else for food they
turn on you and eat you like Ramsay
Bolton and the Game of Thrones reference
but either any way you cut it or or they
they your neighbor who has the food
lures them away right and so now in an
oversaturated environment you have all
these people running around saying hey
come here I'll feed you over here I'll
feed you over here and now there's more
competition in the marketplace and so
and so for me the thing that
differentiates marketing and transmedia
is what kind of food are you are you
feeding your audience is it story or is
it just promotional and and if the
creator is involved and it's part of the
creative vision it's more likely than
not will be more story than it is
promotional if as soon as the creator
disconnects
and hands it off to the digital
marketing people then it they may call
it transmedia but it's probably just
going to be a big marketing ploy